just to give you guys a backstory we're
at the end of a GQ photo shoot and we're
supposed to do this
acting DVD acting video kind of bit for
YouTube
the truth is it's hot as hell and I'm
drunk I took a lot of shots of fireball
whiskey so I'm trying to improv at the
top of my head but the reality is I'm
not sharp right now I'm dull
I am dull this is like performing brain
surgery with the blunt end of a hammer
and speaking of hammered Alison can I
get another one of those shots that
fireball why'd you just bring the bottle
in here so when you show the crowd at
home that I am in fact drinking fireball
whiskey in your first acting lesson
let's say you're at a Jamba Juice and
you see a t-rex how do you act easy you
say oh [ __ ] Rex do you see how I emoted
this lesson is brought to you by
fireball whiskey fireball drink it out
of a paper cup don't be a dick
scenario number two here in the desert
and you see a snake how do you react you
like this oh [ __ ]
[Music]
just just make it about yourself another
[ __ ] snake in the desert with my DVD
course they'll be surprises that will
catch you off guard just like I was
caught off guard let's see you get
pulled over and you have a bunch of weed
in his little box simple do this
Papa sir
I don't have weed in my glove box this
accent at this acting lesson is brought
to you by two bears [ __ ] if you're
playing a parent and your child asks you
where babies came from you simply tell
them the truth from your mom's butt hold
on a second I have to ignite the knife
barb always ignite tonight let's say you
forget about your spouse's birthday and
they confront me about it
simple just be honest now you get my
acting DVD which will teach you to make
a video to then show them which is true
that they were in devious accidents
let's say you were a country star
performing at the Bluebirds in Nashville
how would you command the clown out you
just get them drunk first now this has
been acting with Chris Pratt I hope it
helps I'm guessing it won't just work
out a lot and and use sunscreen and I
can roll the dice fan and remember if
you're working on your plan B you may as
well make it your plan a